okay here's one for you mmm when's a war
war though when you're playing risk Sena
it's always work yes I know the board
game of global domination but seriously
us and Syria war or not okay okay I'll
bite it's a work why I think we all
agree that Syria is in a state of civil
war right now right and America has been
about involved since the very beginning
so they have been supporting opposition
to President Assad's forces they've been
you know supplying weapons and training
moderate rebels and the member means
bombing the countries in September so if
that's not involvement in the war I'm
not really sure what is ok but a counter
to that would be like so many pundits
have been arguing he said this
administration has been really cautious
to put its foot down when I can say
anything regarding Syria yeah they're
working with Turkey but it's more so to
secure that border between Turkey and
Syria and target Isis not create a safe
zone right I don't think anyone is
suggesting that the u.s. is trying to
control a populated area of Syria right
it's more to create a buffer zone for
turkey so that they can resist attacks
but at the end of the day sovereign
territory is being attacked you know and
for many people that's an act of
aggression even if it is against Isis
but you know there's also what we're
seeing is the spillover of you know US
presence in the region especially since
the Iraq war in particular yes it might
not be a war against the Syrian
government or Syria as a country maybe
it's more of you know like a new front
in the global war on terror that seems
to be never-ending and that so-called
war gives the u.s. pretty much carte
blanche to do whatever they want whether
it's you know bombing targets in Syria
or Iraq or you know drone targets in
Somalia Yemen and X time yeah totally
well let's roll it back a bit i mean war
you know violent aggression between
states their international guidelines
for it i mean the UN Charter pretty much
says that in order for you to take
military action against another state
you need to be either restoring
international peace or defending
yourself against a threat of a real
threat a real attack but we both know
that UN charters aren't
you know followed especially when it
comes to the Iraq war too many people
was illegal under international law but
has anyone been prosecuted it's all
political calculation at the end of the
day I mean of course the United States
is not going to quote unquote declare
war against Syria they don't want to get
involved another official at least
quagmire in the region especially after
a bond is gone and you're wrong and I
mean who declares war anymore do you
even have to declare war to be involved
in a war I mean if you think about a DUS
provided the weapons that Israel used in
Gaza last summer they are providing the
cluster bombs at Saudi and their friends
are using in Yemen right now right and
war isn't always about sending in the
ground troops to have this sort of
long-term sustained military campaign I
mean that is such an outdated definition
but if you ask any American right now
what does what look like what are they
gonna say they're gonna say Iraq of
lands on World War One World War two
right when people think of war they
think of Hollywood films you know like a
like a bad guy and a good guy to clear
sides a clear start date and you know
hopefully a clear ending okay how about
this are we now entering a post-war here
or even more to point up where it's not
the word that we think of these you know
heavy military campaigns against a
different country and instead its
operations on a very you know unending
war against an ideology we're not post
war it's not war two point oh I mean I
think we're doing what we've always done
which is change the rules of war
whenever it's convenient to us so that
we can make killing people and taking
land easier bigger issue the Syrian
conflict will not be resolved on the
battlefield that's what this guy told
the UN earlier in September he says the
reason Isis has gotten so strong